hiccup and toothless are the best duo
we've ever seen which is why we just
can't get enough of them with How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world well
on its way
fans are starting to come out with crazy
theories that make way too much sense
watch until the end to find out what the
people of Berk and Dragons have in
common isn't it weird to think that your
hand was inside a dragon like if your
mind was still in control of it two
birds of a feather before hiccup the
friended dragons of all shapes and sizes
the Isle of Berk lived in fear of those
fiery beasts but before long the Vikings
open their hearts to new possibilities
giving birth to a new way of life
instead of hunting dragons the Vikings
learned how to live by their side and
today they ride them like they would a
horse with wings a popular fan theory
that's been circulating around the
Internet is that Bo Nappers and armor
wings are somehow related the popular
opinion is that these two dragons share
a common ancestor which could explain
some of the similarities between them we
mean just look at them they're basically
the same dragon hidden behind different
armor right before we dive into the
similarities between these two breeds
let's find out what makes them
individuals first first on the list is
the big and mighty foe Napper a dragon
who is often looked down upon by its own
kind this probably has everything to do
with the fact that Bo Nappers collect
and wear the bones of deceased dragons
which isn't exactly an endearing
characteristic but if they fail to do
this they'll become nothing more than
prehistoric chickens and that's not a
good look for any one bone knapper spend
all of their time looking for bones that
are suitable for their shape and size in
fact they'll risk their lives to find
the perfect ones unlike normal dragons
bone uppers have soft and squishy scales
which makes them super vulnerable to
attacks of any kind
eret son of eret is super fond of these
magical beasts which is why he chooses
to ride one wherever he goes bone uppers
tend to live in Dragon graveyards and
for the longest time they were thought
to be extinct so could the Boneknapper
be the armored wings long-lost relative
we think so and here's why armored wings
and bone appers are both
Street class dragons who prefer to live
in solitude they have soft scales that
need protection causing them to search
for Armour wherever they go
whereas a Boneknapper goes for bones and
armor wink seeks out metal they have
similar horns and lethal tails and
they're both known for having pale green
skin
however some armored wings are orange
and funny enough sightings of orange
bone Nappers have been documented
however seeing one is super rare so do
we have you convinced if so it looks
like Aaron and snotlout's dragons might
be distant cousins of some sort the Game
of Thrones theory a year after the first
How to Train Your Dragon movie came out
and HBO TV series called Game of Thrones
took the world by storm and while both
these productions had many similarities
one stuck out above all dragons when we
were first introduced to hiccup he's a
timid and clumsy guy who wants nothing
more than to make his father proud but
instead of slaying dragons and becoming
the Viking everyone wants him to be he
befriends dragons and learns how to ride
them a popular fan theory is that hiccup
horrendous is none other than Daenerys
Targaryen 'he's ancient relative in fact
some might say that hiccup is
responsible for the entire Valyrian race
Vikings it's an occupational hazard How
to Train Your Dragon takes place in a
pre medieval setting which fits right
into the game of Thrones timeline on top
of that hiccups a natural when it comes
to handling dragons which could be a
gene that was passed down from
generation to generation
more than that hiccup is bound to marry
Astrid and have kids of his own one day
so perhaps Astrid super fair hair was
carried down in the gene pool creating
the classic valerian look we've all come
to know if you've got your valerian
history down pack then surely you
remember how Valyria was placed in a
desolate part of the world far away from
modern civilization and you'd also know
that malaria was wiped off the face of
the earth when the doom came for the
small islands so could it be that the
Isle of Berk eventually became valaria
and that hiccup and asteroids relatives
escaped to dragons edge for refuge if so
this means that dragons edge and drag
stone are one in the same but with
slightly different names
if hiccups descendants are in fact the
Targaryen then it makes sense that they
would have access to a land in Westeros
after all dragons edge is said to be a
thirty four hour trek from the Isle of
birth oh and here's a coincidence we
just can't ignore actor Kit Harington
who plays Jon Snow in Game of Thrones
also please air it in How to Train Your
Dragon so if this isn't enough to get
you guys on board with this theory we
don't know what is Malka the Scythian
warrior at the beginning of the first
How to Train Your Dragon movie we
learned that hiccups mother was killed
by a dragon when he was just a baby okay
well we learned that she was taken by a
dragon but by Viking law being taken by
a dragon and being killed by one
basically meant the same thing however
during How to Train Your Dragon 2 we
find out that Belka is very much alive
and thriving in a dragon utopia although
Valka is allegedly a Viking there are
some fan theories surrounding her
heritage or rather her fake parentage a
reddit member that goes by the name of
observa wrote a theory that put Falcons
background on the stand and most of her
evidence is too spot-on to be wrong
according to observe Alka isn't a Viking
but rather a Scythian female warrior and
here's why for starters Viking women
weren't allowed to be warriors in fact
they hardly ever joined their husbands
in battle at all instead they stayed
home to raise children and take care of
trivial matters but when it comes to
Scythian warriors women were known for
their excellent fighting skills and
since palca is often referred to as an
amazing warrior we're inclined to think
that she's not a Viking at all Scythian
people live during the same time as the
Vikings did and were known for being
nomadic people who were fond of writing
huge horses in battle Vikings on the
other hand had no love for horses and
preferred to do their bidding on boats
so could it be that stoic and Valka met
and fell in love against all odds we
have to save the Dragons if so it could
explain my balcony like an outcast while
living on the Isle of birth after all
why would she want to run away from her
hometown newborn son and husband
if she was born and raised a Viking from
where we're standing it looks like she
longed for her old life back
but what's forbidden to continue being
the fierce warrior she was raised to be
so when a dragon came to carry her off
she saw it as a way to start a new and
better life an alpha named toothless
although dogs and Dragons are
significantly different they do have
some things in common
mainly they both do whatever their alpha
commands them to do in How to Train Your
Dragon 2 we found out the hard way that
toothless was no match for the bewilder
beasts commands and sadly he blasted
stoic with his fiery powers causing him
to pass away shortly after though
toothless snapped out of his trance and
challenged the alpha to save hiccup from
an untimely death so how did a tiny
dragon take on a big old blue wildebeest
well a popular fan theory is that
toothless was an alpha in the making all
along you just didn't know it yet do you
guys remember when toothless took on the
Red Death in the first how to train your
dragon movie well if you do then surely
you recall how the Red Death was the
Alpha of her path and as the hierarchy
goes dragons who successfully be alphas
take their place at the top knowing this
it makes total sense that other dragons
chose to coexist with the Vikings after
the big battle after all why would any
of them want to live with the Vikings
after being hunted by them for
generations the popular theory is that
toothless is the alpha dragon a bird
however whether or not he was aware of
this is a question we don't have answers
to but once he made the choice to snap
out of the blue wildebeest trance he
began to glow a deep blue before
challenging the Alpha and eventually
beating him so the moral of the story is
that toothless has been an alpha since
the first movie but this assumption
leaves room for suspicion which leads us
into our next Theory toothless the
double agent here's a theory that you
might not fall in love with but hey lame
the internet not us the popular fan
theory is that toothless is a double
agent of some sorts in the first film
hiccup uses his brilliant mind to
fashion a dragon killing device however
after firing it he realizes that killing
dragons
feel as good as he thought it would with
a guilty conscience
hiccup locates toothless and nurses him
back to health and to make up for his
bad deed he creates a device that allows
toothless to fly but there's a catch the
harness is only effective if he controls
it while he's on his back having little
to no options toothless welcomes the
friendship despite knowing that it's
hiccup who shot him down so later on
when it comes time for toothless to save
hiccup from the fiery pits he purposely
latches on to his leg which results in
him losing it so despite saving hiccup
he gets even with him an eye for an eye
right well not quite because the score
is not even yet and here's how the Alpha
Theory ties into the double agent one
despite loving hiccup toothless despised
stoic and how could he not after all he
did murder hundreds of dragons during
his lifespan however killing stoic
out-of-the-blue was too risky so
toothless pretended to be under the
bewilder beasts mind-control knowing
full well that stoic would sacrifice
himself for hiccup this way he could get
his revenge without being punished for
it although we believed toothless to be
as harmless as a puppy we can't deny
that stoic Steph was a little suspicious
after all
toothless came out of his trance for
hiccup a few scenes later but would have
obliterated him seconds before the Isle
of fireproof Vikings believe it or not
that there are some fans who believe
that hiccup and its people are indeed
fireproof or fire resistant at best
while it's true that hundreds of Vikings
have been killed by dragons there's
hardly ever record of them being burnt
to a crisp instead people were eaten
alive or carried away by them on more
than one account we see hiccup and his
friends come inches away from huge
flames without showing any signs of
discomfort if these Vikings could
actually feel the burn they'd be jumping
off their dragons backs as soon as a
flame was thrown their way to support
that notion let's think back to stoic
stead although toothless's blast did
result in him passing away he wasn't
phased in the slightest proving that his
skin wasn't affected by the fire however
toothless says
whoo plasma blast was more than
effective on top of that we all saw
hiccup fall into a field of fire but
this accident only resulted in the loss
of his lower leg and nothing else in
fact every single hair on his head was
intact despite falling headfirst into
the flames this theory sheds even more
light on the targaryen theory at the
beginning of this video which toys with
the notion that the targaryen are
descendants of the Haddock's
this makes complete sense considering
that the targaryen are immune to fire as
well so there you have it guys the six
craziest theories surrounding the How to
Train Your Dragon franchise before you
go let us know which theories you agree
with and which ones do you think are
hogwash and that's a wrap make sure to
subscribe to the things to be first in
line to watch our newest videos thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]